and we're gonna bring it right now mark
short chief of staff to Vice President
Mike Pence who joins us this morning
mark thanks so much for being here
first of all just top-line you're there
at the White House you're around the
vice president the president as these
critical decisions are being made right
before press conferences that everyone
is watching take us behind the scenes of
this process right now
well good morning P thanks for having me
on the task force that meets daily that
the Vice President convenes will be
meeting again this morning at 10 o'clock
typically we bring all sectors of the
government together to bring to the fore
the most important issues and then the
vice president typically raises
decisions that need to be made to the
president but I can't tell you no to
your last segment Pete how encouraged we
are to see all of America coming
together in phenomenal ways the spirit
of America is really inspiring to all of
us and you've seen the private sector
partner and reach out to us and say we
want to retrofit our manufacturing
facilities to provide more medical
supplies if needed we want to be there
to help and provide supplies to those
most in need and we see that from
pastors as well and it's I think we're
very encouraged that we're gonna get
over this hump in and this fan has
typically been six to eight weeks where
we've seen the outbreaks in Asia and
where we've seen them elsewhere and so
um so we're encouraged with the way that
the American people are cooperating with
the 15-day guidance that the president
provided to all Americans mark there's
been a rumor about a nationwide
quarantine can you address that sure
that's a it's not something that's been
discussed inside our task force meetings
is not on the agenda today there are no
plans for a nationwide quarantine and so
in folks see the military mobilized you
know there's rumors of little the
National Guard be listen I've in the
National Guard there's there's no talk
of this there's been no directive of
this and we'll see it you will see it
used in certain place in certain states
to supplement what's happening in health
care places yeah speak to that if you
would so you let's break that down for a
second peak because you're right
typically if National Guard's mobilized
as a governor's direction you know what
we're seeing right now is that three
states have more than 50 percent of
cases and in fact more than 50 percent
of new cases unfortunately for y'all are
in New York City but what we're seeing
is that is that the the the contagion is
really Washington California New York
State and the the fatalities that you
know we were most concerned about
obviously Calif
and Washington New York we're now at it
basically 250 plus what we had said the
president you heard said when initial
numbers came out from the World Health
Organization that the fatality rate was
about three and a half percent among
those here in America were now down
under one and a half percent and I know
that doesn't give comfort to the
families who have lost loved ones but
the reality is that we provide more
information no more people practice
social distancing you're continuing to
see those numbers come down and as we
have more tests out on the market
naturally you're going to see the media
exposure there's more cases that test
positive but at the same time you're
seeing that the fatality rate continues
to come down and and I think as we get
more information we provide more
therapeutics that come on the market in
the coming weeks we're encouraged that
trends going to continue absolutely mark
and in your office it hasn't gone
without touching the vice president's
office we heard reports now that a
staffer in the vice president's office
has tested positive for corona virus
talk to us about that
he's the vice president president have
an interaction with that individual I'm
pleased to report that that individual
is doing well I've talked to him last
night
several times he basically had a couple
days of cold like symptoms he tested
positive Thursday night he was not in
the office Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday he does not he's had no direct
contact with the Vice President or the
president we've had the normal contact
tracing that by the White House
physician's office they go through who
he may have been in contact with
previously and some staff will take
necessary precautions but I'm pleased to
report that that he had very mild
symptoms and and is doing really well
mark this has not been an easy week by
any stretch of the imagination and as we
go into next week you hear just talk
amongst your friends and your family
that we don't know what's gonna happen
next week and there's definitely
concerned testing gonna be ramped up NIH
warning there could be 70,000 cases in
the US by next week dr. Fauci saying
it's unclear when kovat 19 is gonna
reach its peak based upon the
discussions that you have had with the
vice president and the meetings that he
has had and based upon the information
that you're allowed to tell us what do
you anticipate for the next seven days
well tonight I'm pleased to tell you
that with the vice president of
president's leadership we pulled
together a large
number of private sector lab companies
who have provided many more tests on the
market so the number of tests available
has grown tenfold this week alone and
we'll probably see that again next week
so by deduction as more and more people
are tested you're gonna see those
numbers go up but encouraging I think
for your audience is that we've only
been asking people who have symptoms
fever respiratory problems others to get
tested so only those with symptoms are
getting tested and what we're seeing is
less than 10 percent are actually
infected let's keep in mind this is also
flu season it's allergy season and so
the vast majority of people getting
tested are testing negative and even
those who test positive as we've said
from the very beginning the vast
majority of those people do not face a
risk of severe illness the precautions
that this administration has put in
place is out of an abundance of caution
to protect our most vulnerable and them
of the seniors who have underlying
health conditions and that's the
backbone of the policy recommendations
to be extra cautious but what we're
seeing and you will see more and more
people test positive next week as more
tests are available but a lot of people
for instance like the member on our
staff will have very mild symptoms or
actually be asymptomatic altogether mark
well they have a moment here and we're
rightfully focused on how we're reacting
here is the country but there have been
reports recently that if China had acted
sooner if they'd been honest if they'd
had transparency from the beginning a
lot of this could have been prevented
president calling it the Chinese virus
what what is the White House doing to
sort of hold China responsible for
unleashing a lot of this well Pete I
think there's no doubt about that I do
think it's true that if they'd been more
forthcoming from the beginning that it
would have helped other nations to
better prepare for this outbreak having
said that I think there'll be feature
actions down the road right now China
has been trying to provide equipment
where there's deficits to other people
and so I think there'll be further
discussions about responsibly they
should have and should take in ways that
that they were trying to hide
information we also obviously are
concerned about their disinformation
campaigns and alleging that it came from
other places but I think there's
probably gonna be a day at a time as for
for more appropriate actions with China
you got it
well mark short thank you you're a busy
man these days we appreciate taking a
moment for us
thank you Steve thanks for adding me on